so when you first learn calculus you
learned that the derivative of some
function f could be written as f prime
of x is equal to the limit as and
there's multiple ways of doing this the
change in X approaches zero of f of X
plus our change in X minus f of X over
our change in X and you learn multiple
notations for this for example if you
know that Y is equal to f of X you might
write this as Y prime you might write
this as dy/dx which you'll often hear me
say is the derivative of Y with respect
to X and that you could view the
derivative of F with respect to X
because Y is equal to our function but
then later on when you especially when
you start getting into differential
equations you see people start to treat
this notation as an actual algebraic
expression for example you will learn or
you might have already seen if you're
trying to solve the differential
equation the derivative of Y with
respect to X is equal to Y so the rate
of change of Y with respect to X is
equal to the value of y itself this is
one of the the most basic differential
equations you might see you'll see this
technique where people say well let's
just multiply both sides by DX just
treating DX like as if it's some
algebraic expression so you multiply
both sides by DX and then you have so
that would cancel out algebraically and
so you see people treat it like that so
you have dy is equal to Y times DX and
then they'll say okay let's divide both
sides by Y which is a reasonable thing
to do y is an algebraic expression so if
you divide both sides by Y you get 1
over Y DUI is equal to DX and then folks
will integrate both sides to find a
general solution to this differential
equation but my point on this video
isn't to think about how do you solve a
differential equation here but to think
about this notion of using what we call
differentials so a DX or dy and treating
them algebraically like this treating
them as algebraic expressions where I
can just multiply both sides by just DX
or dy or divide both
sides by DX or dy and I don't normally
say this but they're the the rigor you
need to show that this is okay in this
situation is not an easy thing to say
and so to just feel reasonably okay
about doing this this is a little bit
hand wavy it's not super mathematically
rigorous but it has proven to be a
useful tool for us to find these
solutions and conceptually the way that
I think about a dy or a DX is this is
the super small change in Y in response
to a super small change in X and that's
essentially what's what this definition
of the limit is telling us especially as
Delta X approaches zero we're going to
have a super small change in X as Delta
X approaches zero and then we're going
to have a resulting super small change
in Y so that's one way that you can feel
a little bit better of and this is
actually one of the justifications for
this type of notation is you could view
this what's the resulting super small or
what's the super small change in Y for a
given super small change in X which is
giving us the sense of what's the
limiting value of the slope as we go
from the slope of a secant line to a
tangent line and if you view it that way
you might feel a little bit better about
using using the differentials or
treating them algebraically whereas okay
let me just multiply both sides by that
super small change in X so the big
picture is this is a technique that you
will often see in in introductory
differential equations classes
introductory multivariable classes and
introductory calculus classes but it's
not very mathematically rigorous to just
treat differentials like algebraic
expressions but even though it's not
very mathematically rigorous to do it
willy-nilly like that it has proven to
be very useful now as you get more
sophisticated in your mathematics there
are rigorous definitions of a
differential where you can get a better
sense of where it is mathematically
rigorous to use it and where it isn't
but the whole point here is if you felt
a little weird feeling about multiplying
both sides by DX or dividing both sides
by DX or dy you your feeling was is
mathematically justified because it's
not a very rigged
first thing to do at least until you
have more rigor behind it but I will
tell you that if you're an introductory
student it is a reasonable thing to do
as you explore and manipulate some of
these basic differential equations